this is the video game industry any time
of the year outside of e3 delicious and
this is e3 see how it leaks its GameSpot
news time before we get into all of that
and you need for Speed game is coming
out this year EA and developer ghost
games have today confirmed that there
will be a new Need for Speed
this year though details are a little
scant in a press release ghost games
hinted that they are committed to
customization and police pursuits in
addition they've also shared that their
focus is on making the game's world
beautiful with plenty of things to do
including off-road driving stating
you're going to want a world that not
only looks beautiful but offers you the
space in which to do the things you want
we're dialing up the action and allowing
you to tear up the tarmac and dirt to
your heart's content elsewhere in the
release ghost games confirmed that this
year's Need for Speed will not be always
online unlike its 2015 predecessor more
information will be shared in the run-up
to EAS III 2017 event EA play look
Tekken 7 the fighting game that won't
feature fighting kangaroos thanks to us
the Australians and our pension for
punching kangaroos is going to get a ps4
pro bundle in Europe ooop playstation
France and UK announced the bundle on
Twitter which comes with a ps4 pro 1
terabyte and a copy of Tekken 7 which is
obviously a Tekken 7 bundle there will
also be a 500 gigabyte ps4 slim version
too for those of you who don't need that
many Peas a listing on UK retailer games
website shows a price of 250 pounds for
the slim Edition but it's not clear what
the pro version will cost side note I
had to write out the word pounds in my
script because I don't know where the
symbol is on my keyboard so if you know
help me out and just let me know in the
comments below thanks there's no word on
if the bundles will be making their way
across the pond the US but we'll let you
know if we hear anything another token
news a pair of players have been banned
from an upcoming Tekken 7 tournament
following accusations of collusion at a
qualifying event Bandai Namco posted on
their Facebook page that district G king
J and District GC chris'll not their
real names will not be participating in
the UK championship London qualifier on
May 14 instead the player spots will go
to the next two highest placements RTFM
Assam and edk justice again not their
real names King J weighed in on the
matter via Twitter to dispute the claim
stating I don't know where this
collusion stuff is coming from and that
it won't be responding further quote
because it's pure nonsense as a result
of these events
bandai namco will be altering its
rulebook to have a clear claws on
collusion it's finally time to know what
all that was about and it's finally time
for a new Assassin's Creed game at least
according to some leaks get it first
reported by wwg and corroborated by
Eurogamer sources have claimed that a
prequel called Assassin's Creed origins
will launch for ps4 Xbox one and PC
later this year meanwhile over on the
internet soapbox reddit an off-screen
image purporting to be the first look at
origins has been posted check out that
sweet boat you may remember that early
last year Kotaku reported that the next
Assassin's Creed game would take place
in Egypt we're sure to get more info at
e3 so make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any of our coverage direct
from the show floor and that's
everything from GameSpot news for today
I've been down crowd have yourselves a
fantastic Tuesday and I've got a 5:00
p.m. kangaroo punching so I got to get
out of here